وأشكر جميع مواطنينا هناك
من الجولة الأولى ارتدى بهم
يصوت على ترشيحي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يعبر عني ويجعلني
شرف التأهل للثاني
بدوره في مواجهة الرئيس المنتهية ولايته سواء
يسمح للتعبير عن نعم القراء الذين لدي
لم يظهروا ثقتهم أكثر
الشحن الصادق
تدابير خطة بتواضع جميع
المسئولية
[موسيقى]
الأنديز
كن رياضيات
ناضجة وبلدي
الفتاة عقد
[موسيقى]
24 أبريل المقبل يمكننا القيام به
اختيار حقبة فرنسية جديدة
والأوروبية في 24 أبريل نستطيع
اختر الأمل في 24 أبريل
يمكننا اختيار فرنسا
وأوروبا معا تحيا
جمهورية
وتحيا فرنسا
أنا أعول عليكم
[موسيقى]
ما سيتم لعبه في 24 أبريل ليس كذلك
فقط تصويت الظروف ولكن
اختيار المجتمع وحتى
حضارة صوتك وليست في
تأثير في جميع أنحاء فرنسا
الرجحان الشرعي للثقافة و
من اللغة الفرنسية للولايات المتحدة و
عادات مناطقنا وطرق
حياة القوانين والقيم الفرنسية
الجمهوريون في مقدمتهم
العلمانية والمساواة ، ولا سيما بين
رجال ونساء
[موسيقى]
ولا أعتقد أنه يُمنح رؤية مدام لو
القلم لست مخطئا من الخصم
هذا هو سبب من
يدعو الناخبين للتصويت ل
مارين لوبان
أين
الانتعاش الاقتصادي بعد الوباء
الخلق
الذي - التي
لأنها
م
أنني مجتمع
[موسيقى]